the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody to the 2022 summer
chest classic a couple of round robin
tournaments that he we have here for you
edison lewis chess club i am grand
master alejandro ramirez here to bring
you all of the action with my good
friend grandmaster christian carrillo
alejandro always a pleasure to be here
in studio b with you we've been spending
a lot of time in studio a finally we are
rekindling uh in studio b and let's look
at the standings after the first round
which happened yesterday we're going to
start off with group a alejandro yeah we
have two very strong round robins for
you ten players each and
if you're tuning in this is not the same
field cup this is not the us
championship but it is really really
close to being that strength if you look
at the list of players here it's
incredibly strong we have an average
rating of well over 26.50 and standings
for group a very simple from round one
everybody drew their game yesterday
everybody's time for first everybody's
tied for last nothing much to talk about
here most of the players that started
with the black pieces are probably happy
about that one but it's not a big deal
indeed the easiest standings i've ever
seen right now how about group b
alejandro what do we have there because
we did have a couple of decisive results
in that one yeah and group b standings
are quite interesting because brandon
jacobson one of the black pieces
yesterday against nico cheka and camille
dragoon demolished jojon chow with the
white pieces yesterday and fascinating
match up today because they actually
play each other
today we'll get into that a little bit
later but let's take a look at the
format first as we have for you guys two
template around robins as i was
mentioning uh nine rounds of course 90
minutes for the first 40 moves very
traditional classical trust 30 minutes
for the rest of the game and you get a
30 second increment throughout which is
how most chess tournaments run nowadays
and the schedule is actually quite easy
as well we started off yesterday
thursday june 2nd with the first round
every single round up to the last one
which will happen on friday june 10th is
going to start at 1 pm central time the
last round is going to start two hours
earlier at 11 a.m central time if
necessary and we do have the playoffs
that's going to happen at 5 00 pm on
june 1st that's right and join the
discussion here at uh the st louis chess
club join us in any kind of social media
we have
summer chess classic on twitch i will be
watching the youtube and the twitch uh
chats today so if you want to join the
conversation just chat away i'll be
catching up on the best questions
and for uh everybody that's up or
following us on twitch a special
announcement that for every 75 that we
receive on bids on subs on any kind of
donations via this medium for every 75
we'll be giving a full semester of
collegiate programming of collegiate of
chess programming for students here at
the st louis chess club imparted by
grand masters so help us out this isn't
going into our pockets it's going
straight into helping just progress for
kids around the area it's one of the
most important missions of the saint
louis chess club to pick players from
the foundation level all the way to the
us chess championship level all the way
to the sinkfield cup level and we have
examples uh to show you for that you see
jeffrey sean for example who went all
the way to the u.s championship and
right now is a contender this is an
important mission and if you can help us
we would greatly appreciate it now how
about
the pairings for group a what do we have
there alejandro let's get into the
nitty-gritty we got a lot of interesting
pairings i think the ones that caught my
attention ray robson against sabi manu
mishra ray robson already an established
player but still under 30 so he's quite
young he's playing a uh barely a
teenager abimenum mishra of course the
youngest grandmaster in the world has
really dazzled us he did a fantastic job
in the spring chess classic here and
earned his spot in the summer chess
classic a group by winning the b group
last time he played uh other interesting
matchups today jacobian against savion
is going to be great glendora smearing
is going to be very interesting and of
course jonas beer i guess my student he
calls theodore that goes to saint louis
university is going to be quite
interesting but
the match-up of the round in round
number two is of course the one between
grisha alparina seed number three going
into this event against the top seed of
the event the chinese yu yang yi who is
playing for the first time here at the
saint louis chess club and we see the
two players engaged right now in a
fierce battle i have to say i'm seeing
the white king on g1 and all the pawns
uh in front of his king already quite
advanced uh very interesting position
alejandro yeah actually i had forgotten
about something you had played here
before he did indeed yeah he we kind of
forget about it because that's what
kasparov played and everybody was
focused on kasparov oh you're right he
played the same let's drop it in blitz
here he did play saint louis rabbit and
blitz yeah but so he's a strong player
he can play saint phil cop he can play a
similar trap in a blade or he could play
one of the classic series let's take a
look at what's happening in this uh
match we are not using engines for this
because it's a 90 minute show and
why do we need to use that why not let's
have some fun
some of the stuff we say might be wrong
but not that wrong something that's not
having fun is uh the light square bishop
in black's position the bishop on h7
this guy is not having any fun as of
right now potentially it could open up
if you manage to get an f5 and i think
this is what he's gunning for
right now now
quite an interesting moment came a
couple of moves ago
um when this happened after nightway two
we see the tension between the pawn on
c5 and the pawn on d4 in the center
quite an interesting tension and right
now black decides to play this move c4
do you agree with this move alejandro
i kind of understand the idea of it
it goes back to what you mentioned of
this light squared bishop the slight
square bishop has a lot of difficulties
returning to the queen side it doesn't
have a good diagonal to zigzag its way
back so if you ended up taking on d4 and
there's a lot of positions like that if
you go back a couple of moves if you
take on d4 in this position and i take
the queen just just put a couple of
moves in exchange and you exchange
things take the queens off the board get
right back to whatever yeah somewhere
something like this and i'm not saying
this is precise or whatever but just
look at the potential of this knight on
g2 to return to the fight in the
in the queen side you can go 93 94 you
can go knight f4 knight d3 uh there's a
lot of things hitting on that side the
bishop on g6 is not going to participate
on that side of the board and i think
that's where the danger comes in exactly
and uh just as we exchanged this couple
of pawns the c pawn for the d-pawn also
we don't have a plug against the bishop
on b3 now the main idea in the position
that we currently have on the board for
black is to go f5
with the pawn
already exchanged and this light square
bishop opened up you don't have the move
f5 yeah because your pawn on e6 is going
to hang all the time so i like this a
lot i like this idea i like this movie
for a lot i don't know how good it is
because i get no engines but
it it's it's very charming to
to play a move like this because you
don't see it very often i've never seen
c4
exactly so it just changes the character
of the position and really this was this
was a very interesting moment for me
because i think i would have
probably played bishop b1 i i i not give
the bishop yeah not give the bishop i do
value bishops pretty highly and i don't
know if gregory apart in values bishops
as well i can tell you that much yeah
he loves the two bishops and he decided
against uh keeping keeping bishops which
is quite an interesting decision now
obviously you ask yourself what are you
going to do with the a1 i think that's
the main problem right huge problem yes
yeah that's a really big issue the rick
just doesn't go anywhere even if you
develop it through a3 it's targeted by
the bishop on east yeah and i i can
guarantee you after rook to c1 if you
give me one more move i'm going to go
bishop to b1
but you don't you take on c2 uh you grab
the light square bishop and now
when uh f5 is going to rise on the board
then the light square bishop is going to
open up quite nicely create some havoc
in white's position so i do like what's
happening right now knight to f4 so
what's your uh what's your knee jerk
reaction why it's better or black is
close to equal
there's definitely no way that black's
better here
right i feel white is better and i
kind of understand
like for example if i don't have this
idea in my back pocket this rook to g2
idea yeah followed by potential g5 g5 at
some point yeah i know exactly when at
some point now this is a matter of
tempest right because if you do get f5
right in a good version and you open up
the light square bishop then you can
easily be better as black but i really
like this idea of taking with the rook
on c2 i think it's it's quite masterful
rook g2 and g5 is very visually
difficult to parry
i like white too i just i think the flow
of the game is going more in white's
favor time is about even
and i'm looking at options right now so
for example queen to e7 right let's say
queen to e7 defend upon on e6 and before
rook d8 is coming yeah yeah that looks
like you know f5 right even if you do
get this move f5 i can now open up the g
file and then just go e5 the thing is
many in many cases you don't want to
give up the d5 square but the knight on
f4 is a great blockader you're still
controlling fd5 you're controlling g6
and checking ideas of this nature right
now boom boom
oof
yeah this is horrible uh i agree
as you were mentioning things are
flowing floyd
tactics tend to flow in white's favor
because of the peace activity so it's
not it's not surprising that we take
white in this position i expect that
black should be a lot more patient that
it's not so bad but i would prefer to be
white uh we haven't actually gotten into
the pairings of the b group so let's uh
let's jump there before we get too
engrossed in a group
um big group remember that camille
dragon is playing
uh against brandon jacobson and that's
going to be the pairing of the day you
see it here at the end uh the reason
it's appearing of the day is because
both of them won their game yesterday
also camilo is one of the higher rated
players in the tournament if not the
higher the player highest rate actually
the highest rate is on depot
but some interesting matches for me this
is very clear though brandon against
camille it would have been the game of
the day before the day started
unfortunately we do start our broadcast
a little late and by this point i think
that game is more or less dead we can
probably just check it for one you think
so i'm not convinced yeah
still a game here yeah absolutely and
we're going to get into that in just a
second and as you can see you were
mentioning this is a quite intriguing
match up not only because these two
players are very explosive in their
styles but also because they won
yesterday yeah which is very important
right you set the tone early in the
tournament then when when only two
people win in round one and they face
each other there's this danger that one
of them wins again and just catapults
himself
above the field right because a lot of
draws might happen and that might become
a full point so this kind of second
round pairings between leaders tend to
be quite important for the future of the
tournament and what we're saying here is
that well black has a lot of activity
for the what is currently a missing pawn
but the question is can white really do
anything because f2 is hanging well i'm
not going to defend this game you cannot
defend it if you defend with rook i'm
not going to go rooker i mean
okay probably pick this one up i pick
this one up and you have to defend i'm
probably going to set up the blockade
with rokon a2 yeah work on b2
controlling b6 at all times you can
never get that
you have to keep the rook here to defend
the f2 pawn there's no way you can get
out of this i i agree there's no there's
no so you have to take one exactly what
he has done
he did yeah yeah and he i assume you
take on f2 with the rook
just because it's a tempo that's that's
an idea
uh
you're probably gonna sidestep
there's no choice another question is
are you going to continue picking up
pawns
right i could go the thing is i could
take on f3 here sure but i'm also
wondering why do i care about this part
on f3 right
that's a good question but my plan is
very simple you're just going to put it
on
a5 b6 i'm not going to remove the bishop
from a6 because the bishop a6 is
defending the b5 pawn how do you defend
against that i'll give you all my pawns
on the king side i actually wonder
i like your plan i'm not gonna say i
don't like i love your plan i think it's
very precise i am wondering if from a
practical point of view for white
it's better to throw in king g2 at some
point because i'm thinking that right
now i could take on h3
sure how do you continue okay and i'm
just going to put a rook on like b3 or
b2 or whatever you just want to i just
want to give up my bishop on b6 so
you're aiming for this type of
situations let's say i'm just making
something yeah and then b and then you
just take it take take and obviously
this is just a draw is it drawing you're
not even going to get working bishop in
this particular setup precisely you're
not even going to get that far precisely
so
this one we know it's a draw now the
question is
let's get back to this
oh my goodness quite far away you are
mentioning that you want to preserve the
last pawn on the king side yeah maybe go
k2
that makes a lot of sense
but now i get an extra tempo
i just wasn't sure
if it mattered you know one of those
positions where you're not sure if the
tempo is worth more than the than the
pawn itself what i i agree that i was uh
hasty in calling this a draw what has
some chances um i'm not entirely sure
how you draw it cleanly can you go back
to the position i want to see how many
how much time camille has five minutes
yeah for camille doesn't worry because
he has 16 moves to make and then 35 uh
minutes for random that's quite
impressive
because some of these decisions are
going to be difficult for black like do
you take on f3 do you not take on f3 do
you go back with the rook
even taking on f2 right now is not so
clear if you want to take with the
bishop and go bishop d4 or if you want
to go rook f2 so a lot of little
considerations to be made here by
camille he's running out of time yeah
he's really running out of time
that's a big problem he's look brandon
is definitely putting some practical um
decisions in front of his opponent i i
totally agree with difficult decisions i
think it's i think they're very far from
easy uh that being said today in
particular group a is just absolutely
exploding
excellent and i want to see a lot of the
games we're just going to go quick quick
quick quick uh let's start with ray
robson against abi
uh we're very told by our amazing
producer shout out to ben simon that
we're gonna look at the price ones first
while i actually refresh my chat
uh i will be looking at that as well and
actually let's start with the price one
in group a as we can see quite a
handsome price fun 22 000
6000 goes to the victor 4 thousand to
second place thousand third place going
all the way down to the last place one
thousand dollars and what about the b
group the b group is of fourteen
thousand dollars almost fifty percent
but not quite some of the prices are
actually higher like second but
uh also a very good way of supporting
chess here a lot of these players they
have uh trouble playing tournaments
where you're not winning any money where
you're not really playing for cash
prizes here we give all your
accommodation we buy the players the
tickets so they're playing just for
profit and it allows a lot of these
talents to be able to keep playing chess
in the circuit
all right so with that being said let's
go straight into the games because
they're they're kind of wild and this is
a very limited time show
and we have tons of tons to cover but i
think this is where we should start uh
not
like i don't want to spend too much time
in this position i just want to give it
some kind of evaluation and move on i
wanted to i was more interested in the
middle game
starting with the move queen g5 so this
is
yeah by the way this is some bad thing
right it ha it's a bottom minute yeah
it's a bad winning semi sloth
the whole thing bishop g5 knight a6
some sort of a theory some sort of
theory the players were already like
spending some time here but after queen
g5 queen f8 which actually was i think a
very cool move
queen to f bishop e2 abby played this
really cool move c5
opening up the bishop opening up the
bishop giving up a pawn and it looks
like it gives up a pawn it does but so
for example you know i take c5 rook d5
and this is kind of the point i think i
wasn't sure i didn't really check it so
long and then you take on c5 and i think
maybe black has some kind of maybe even
you can start with rook f5 i don't know
if i take only six so you probably have
to well you need this knight first rook
two five i think i take on that and then
e6
but then i take a queen what do you mean
and i ah
you're a piece up at the end of it yes
yes yes
for whatever reason i thought that i'm
uh already a piece of piece
yeah yeah yeah
so rook to f5 quite early maybe because
of rook f5 you just lost it
the queen is completely trapped that's
pretty funny so you can't go there which
makes
a response to rook d5 kind of awkward i
mean you could go queen j3 queen e3 but
you're not really playing for an
advantage here exactly now i can just
simply take take take with the queen
maybe
even yeah this looks good this looks
good for black yeah so he goes bishop f3
and then a lot of traits happen which is
kind of funny because
abby didn't want to trade the queens on
e7 or g5 but now he wants to try them
because he got c5 in it's like this
little detail also because he's already
doubled up on the h file exactly so
little details that you know you see the
queen on e7 not ready to be captured
uh by black and moves it around but on
h6 it is i love it no he's uh
he's playing well yeah basically this
young man the newcomer in the a group
because he actually won
the big group a couple of months ago
right now he's uh facing all of these
monsters this is a high level
competition that he hasn't faced up to
this point so it's going to be
quite an interesting point in his career
to see if he can handle this type of
pressure yeah this is the first time he
plays against players of this caliber
he's had on and off games against 2600
but never a full tournament against such
an average rating so definitely a big
task for him but so far he's impressed
he started actually with two blacks uh
against two of the highest rated players
uh drew sevian easily yesterday with the
black pieces and today he's playing
against uh robson in this obviously
complicated ending i'm not really sure
who's better
i mean so let's go all the way in and by
the way roxanne has three minutes oh my
goodness i mean typically typical ray
ray but three minutes three minutes
three minutes a little for 12 more moves
yeah it's a little extreme complicated
situation because you have so many
options for both sides right it's so
imbalanced you see this position this
type of end game six versus six actually
six never mind five versus five my
counting days are long oh yeah yeah we
left those
we know that we know that already take
on b5 rook takes p5 probably is going to
happen and we have this battle
of weaknesses right now and the position
black is uh targeting the weakness on b2
and white is potentially ready to
promote the pawn
i actually you know
what if i can't even tell you which side
i prefer exactly it's such a complicated
end game so do i go for your a pawn
probably not because i do have this
option to go here exchange potentially
this guy and then now you don't have
knight to f6 knight to h7 to stop my
pawn you're not in time
to get to the pawn with the king because
this just simply loses
not in time
so
you have to put your rook on a very
passive square h8 most likely
now once you get there i'm going to
start picking up your pawns who's better
i mean white can't be worse but
i don't know if you're winning
this scares me for black and i think i
would pull the plug as you know because
bishop a4 maybe i can just go rookie
five
it's just a better move ah
i just i don't know if it is but it
looks to me like it should be so what if
i go up and then and then here now you
have check you have checks and then you
cannot take on c4 because knight b6 i
mean maybe you can but no this is too
suspicious right you can just simply i
can take on a bad day but i think rook
d3 rook f3 was super strong yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so even here after king
to b3 you cannot go on the fourth rank
because you're before going up so yeah
bishop you have to attack the rook but
you now go to f3 yeah now black is
you're getting a lot of compensation a
lot
yeah a lot of dynamic play in the
position so this this is actually what's
scary for me for robson is that i don't
see this as clear nothing is simplified
at any point no and he has one minute
and 40 seconds on the clock yeah
so we're going to let him think i'll
keep an eye on this one
just because we have so much going on i
will ask you to change to the beer sure
bear theodore game because it's just
such craziness oh my goodness yeah it's
such a crazy position on both sides in
time pressure theodore with only 7
minutes
and beer with 19 white is currently up a
pawn
but
the position has exploded
there's a bishop on h3 there's tactics
like you get like rook h25 the idea is
that if you take on h3 i can just simply
take on e5 or rook h5 it doesn't mean
tactical rook to h5 but both work but
yeah rookie five looks stronger yes go
uh there and the problem is that not
only that you cannot take but you also
cannot defend the g file very well
because after a queen to g3 same thing
the same g5 the same idea you pick up
the rook i'm going to get double attack
and i'm going to pick up the queen now
this is a typical
nikko
oh my god nico king's india this type of
structure this is nico written all over
it the crazy the
one side is down material but there's
tricks everywhere but there's no more
bishop on g7 so what happened to this
one how did we get here actually
so we did get some sort of a king's
indian e5
we've seen this yesterday with brandon
brandon he listened to the interview and
he analyzed that game he liked it
you know that very well um i'm going to
speed through this one because they're
actually playing a lot of moves very
quickly right now so they have to be
right
wait wait knight f7 was played check
this out
f7 e5 is coming
so you're going to start with rook to h5
right yeah i think starting with rook h5
is just so much more logical right
correct so let's start with rook to h5
okay i i just don't see why not but
defense after e5 not only that i'm
targeting the knight on f6 but i'm also
having bishop to hg6 coming and that's
probably going to have devastating
consequences for the safety of your king
you're probably going to get checkmated
yeah this looks lost
doesn't look great no i think you're
throwing rock h5 so let's go rook h5
now
i don't see a better square for this
queen than
g3 g3 right
it feels like the natural option also
maybe at some point but not yet that's
the problem
if you take on f7 i take on h3 you go to
g5 again
this annoying uh motif in the position
queen's g5 knight to f3 let's just be uh
greedy yeah rook h5
you don't have queen g3 king takes f7 g
takes h3 so what is the idea e5 that's a
very good question probably e5 but if i
let's say i just even if i just take
with the e-rook
how do we evaluate this at the end but
then i take
king e7 i continue
getting your king to e6 you have to keep
contact with the knight on f6 i think i
do even though i'm not guaranteeing
that's true i think that's true
what a weird position
because
my rookie fights later
let's keep going
i want to take advantage of the fact
that your queen is very much out of the
game right now yeah
so you got that once you get to e3 now
that your rook is no longer protected i
want to by the way before we get too
deep into this by the way rookie five
was playing rook h5 queen g3 let's say i
actually wanted to look at another move
uh queen g3 is kur i think my biggest
it's not yet on the board no but yes
i was thinking can you play knight takes
e4
you can probably play a lot of moves
around here knight takes e4 wait that's
something that i did not consider what
if i just simply take and i take with
the rook
ah because now i cannot continue taking
you cannot continue taking and the funny
thing is even though my rook is hanging
on my bishop is hanging you can't take i
oh you can take on h3 now because your
knight on f7
defense g5
no more g5 oh no
what is that i get that but now you can
just simply take on f7
i could but i'm not up material but
that's a big problem rook g5 is a big
problem what a crazy position and you
don't have any checks my king is on f7
but you have zero checks not even queen
to c7 yeah the queen is finally
so you probably have to play something
along the lines of king to
g2 maybe king g2 is actually not above
but king f1 maybe or king to f1 i liking
f1 just sidestep all this stuff
hide everything hydra yeah but this
actually might be strong
yes yes the question is
even if we count the position down like
rook to e6 right
just
just positional yeah
how bad is this position i understand
that i don't know i don't i don't know
but i do have this monitor it's a good
night it's a very good night that my
king on f1 is still
weak and the rook on a1 is not playing
for at least a couple of moves right i
need my queen
i need my queen back into play on a5 is
not doing anything no
queen v8 and i was even thinking like if
you go rookie one just because of that
thought process maybe go queen v6
defend the road just defend the rook try
to get
yeah so now if you take i take with the
queen
i defend this pawn in the process three
and continue
and now if you take take take i'm just
going to peter out to probably a draw
yeah
probably
seems like an equal position so this is
the situation that we have right now on
the board rook to h5 was played they
want to run an engine and see how much
of that would go right quinto g3 was
played
not that bad
so i've already got that right
but it's zero zero zero zero with king
f7 but rookie four ninety four loses
right yes knight takes e4
takes rook takes and ig5 of course
of course
so you take
take and of course you don't take here
you actually go knight g5 hits every
piece on the board yeah well
but it's not that clear because
the most important aspect of this
position is that after rook to g4 now
the on g5 cut the action of
the rook and i have queen to e5 oh
that's pretty difficult if you don't but
you know what another you know what
another beautiful point of this is yes
is that if you go queen takes c3 here
queen takes e3 actually pins your knight
otherwise this would work absolutely
otherwise this would work for a black
yeah it it it would indeed no that's
funny it's such a wild position
five minutes five minutes for nico's
what really worries me because
i mean you can't and by the way we're at
moon 19. i'm not even close to mu 40.
not even
close no
it's like
it's like the players look that yeah we
just started the game i mean it's like
the players looked at yesterday and they
said that was a really boring round how
do we change it up how do we mix it up
how do we make it as exciting as
possible for the fans so by the way okay
let's i'm turning off the engine yeah
yeah e5 king of 75 yeah he's played king
f7 and e5 instantly on the board and
that makes a lot of sense but that makes
very easy moves e5 is a very easy move
to make
and he's putting tremendous pressure
on the knuckles right now
because you have so many options right
at the same time as black you can take
with the rook from h5 you can take with
the rook from the eighth e8
you can go knight to f5 that's an option
as well but knight to f5 has these
drawbacks the main one being that you
lose probably the most active piece in
the position tonight on d4 yeah that's
true but let's let's go down that a
little bit knight f5 takes state take
what do you take with i think with the
bishop because i not with the pawn to go
rook to g8
begs con consideration as well yeah i
was just worried that after context f6
ruxia you have root d7
and if i go king to f8 right now you
have g7
not
yeah that's a mate yes um but okay
knight f5 i think i wanted to take with
the bishop okay so that on pawn takes f6
i had rook e8
there's no chucks
but i think maybe f3 is
it's just about safe enough for white
surprisingly give the king to f2 right
and maybe that's just it like there's
nothing here so what if i go here
how are we doing on pawn so you are two
pawns up as white yeah two pawns up
there's absolutely nothing wow
yeah i don't think the king just hides
hides on v2 the problem is you cannot
take on f6 because
because of queen c7 i agree with you
this is too artificial three minutes and
30 seconds for nico uh
super sharp position
no absolutely um we're actually going to
check oh my goodness
i see something on f5 i think it's a
bishop a bishop my man bishop to f5
okay so if i take on f6 do i do the same
oh because rook on a1 is hanging at the
end right so like if i go
this
yeah you could take with a queen in this
move order but
that's the point right right
and the knight on d4 is defending d7 so
so if you do go f3 the very safe f3
um unfortunately
your king is not that safe anymore well
the king is safe but the rokuni one is
not
and i assume this is good for white
for
black for black sorry sorry yes yes
the problem is you cannot move the
knight right you would love to get the
knight involved into the attack but
queen
checkmate on the board
finishes the game so um
that's not possible okay so we
understand that rook takes d3 is
probably losing how about queen takes d3
maybe for that reason i invert the move
order like i wanted to take on f6 rook
had immediately ah i see i see that way
on f3
right
so you maybe have to play f4
[Music]
what a wild position it's just crazy
right so many details what a wild
position
f1 might not be like what white wants to
play but it looks pretty so the idea
being that you need to keep connection
of the queen with the bishop one d3
otherwise you're first take back with
rook and then the rook on one is hanging
um
let's uh go well actually we do have the
first result of uh the day that's crazy
group that is absolutely crazy yes quite
late three rounds in yesterday actually
before we went live we already had about
two reasons
now we're just getting the first one and
that is antipov who drew his game
against nicolas checkout in the big
group anything happened there
no okay absolutely
um
we're probably going to have to stay
with this one
unless beer is ready to be taking a
longer thing you want to
no that's not not the on type of game
don't worry about it i am i'm not on
that uh perfect all right let's take a
look at gledura versus
what is happening in this one
by the way gledura we thought uh
yesterday that he had great chances to
win yeah
in that end game against you young e
unfortunately for him he was unable to
do so
but
right now does he have an advantage he
does have an extra pawn
a lot of questions here in the
chat i've been missing is ray robson the
favorite to win hmm
why not no no no no no no no
no why why would he it's hard to beat
it's hard to bet against 2700s when they
play in tournaments
pretty good yeah it's it's very
difficult to uh to say the fourth seed
is actually the top dog yeah in the
event um i would say you're one of the
favorites
yeah
not
necessarily the clear favorite because
we have sam savion who's just
on the uh uprising in the last few
months he's definitely on the up and up
up and up 2703 he's been facing the big
guns and doing very well and doing
amazing yeah yeah he barely lost against
fabiano caron and in the american cup i
mean yeah
that was such a that was such a thriller
that match all right let's go let's go
to the games uh glendora is where you
wanted to take us uh it looks like white
is up
upon
i can't really say that white house
black has any compensation and i'm
actually wondering if
white is
just winning another pawn because 93
knight takes c4 is it's a problem it's a
bit of an issue and i i see the problems
okay well black has some open files and
stuff like that but they're not actually
throwing anything
so
let's try to
get the last array out of this pawn on
c4 is the knight knight d3
e3
my goodness there's actually no way to
defend that yeah because you would like
to play bishop f4 but it just loses to
rook takes d3
exactly
take take and actually your pawn is not
going in not going anywhere
knights are nicely protecting against
any sort of
idea of promotion um looks pretty good
and if you do take on e3 then i take
back with the rook that's that piece up
game over
yeah fish before rook takes
so 9393 looks like
game over i think so
so what do you do that's black
how
do you make any progress by the way that
knight on f3 is beautiful this is
absolutely everything looks busted to me
i'm going to turn on the engine no i
think this might be yeah it's plus it's
completely bad it's completely busted i
mean yeah yeah the more we look at it
the more boss that we think it is by the
way he did play the move knight yeah 93
and then just like plus 493 like there's
nothing going on you're up to pawns and
you're going to win more wow yeah
gladua awesome start there he had a good
game yesterday against your young he
wasn't able to convert i think if he
converted he would have been super happy
but still uh coming back and beating
smearing with the white pieces or with
any pieces
is quite an achievement so good for uh
benjamin there i we're not going to say
that i know i am going to say yeah this
is too much a player of ledgus
i think wins this not only that is too
much but it's also quite easy right
because there's no counter chances
coming from black's perspective right
now knight takes c4 is coming there is i
don't see a good way to defend against
knight xc4
um
there's no way to get my king it plays
itself yeah it's such an easy position
for
the white side i would assume bishop f4
is what he wants to do and after rook
takes d3 he's probably going to resign
all right let's uh move on to another
big match the one between hercobian and
savion because we haven't
talked about it
okay
maybe this is why we haven't talked
i mean what is a bit better
ish okay a little bit yes
it's an advantage whether it's very real
or not
something else
still not sure who's playing for an
advantage here
uh really
definitely well knight to e6 is coming
right i think i play
i would consider even king of four here
but
sure king to f4 and knight is
six no it's not my king yeah if i get
made it i don't care can you eat five
kinky five kingy seven am i actually
getting made in
you're one move away from getting baited
f6 is a mate yeah but okay and if you
take take yeah you're not really going
to work to see two yeah i mean or to see
one if you go here i go here that's why
it's not better here definitely not but
maybe even slightly worse um and this is
exactly what i'm asking because yeah i
think it's just equal i think i think
white needs to hold pull down pull back
the brakes at some point and just yeah
just equalize
i do have control of the c file and i do
have the d pawn um so yeah on the other
hand i could play rogue d2 maybe just
keep pretending right because rook c2
only one side's playing for the win in
the night end game and it is white it's
probably a draw though yeah yeah
cool
[Music]
what's um oh my goodness
oh my god a lot of things have happened
yeah the punk it although it's a decent
in this game between grigori and you
young he and i see grigory with only
four minutes right now
on the clock and the position just
simply exploded from where we left it i
think we left it somewhere around knight
to f4 i think this is one of the great
things about these like strong players
establish strong players like you're
young
take a look at the like the sequence
starting we left it out for 27. don't
look at anything just look at your
endings clock
22 2208
2119 playing super fast
21-42 blitzing out his moves 21-22
goodness
he's so fast he plays so fast he's just
so fast and now now you get this
complicated position where maybe that
was not an easy position and that was
not an easy position at all now you've
got another complicated position where
white has three minutes left and your
knee just playing so fast creating all
this tension outside of the board it's
something you can't see over the board
but you look at the clock and you know
that the situation right now for gregory
is pressure oh yeah a lot of pressure
because he has to find a lot of moves in
this complex position against a very
strong player who's playing instantly
well i have no idea what's happening i
have to say because c takes
to be honest the more i look at the
position the more i like black because
queen to g3
is a devastation
will be a threat once you remove the
queen from the c file
i understand probably a good idea to get
the knight close the king but what about
queen to g3
reinforcing the threat and i don't have
to go to g3 maybe i can go to h3
reinforcing the threat of knight takes
f3
how do you continue
by the way knight to g2 three minutes
and 23 seconds
for grigorio powering
still 18 minutes for you
so quinto g3
i see that you're uh you're calculating
something i don't see anything
how do you defend against knight takes
f3 do you have to go like queen do you
want big question
yeah but
i guess you
you actually have to go but quindy one
probably just loses how
i think i just take on b
and the problem is i don't have these
seven because the a yeah this is what i
couldn't make work and i don't see a
good way wait i do have bishop f4
boom
boom boom yeah here i was thinking
knight f3 but i forgot to take with the
rook now with the queen yep yep that's
important and on bishop c5
can i go bishop see my first time oh you
can go first c5 first uh it's a big
issue because now you have queen to each
three check yeah you have to drop back
with but the bishop you take on d7 and
you win yeah
um and by the way none of this will
happen because h3 first three was played
and it gets a lot of stuff it's so fast
the guy plays so fast quindy one played
instantly in response so much pressure
also
right now ten more moves to make before
the time control with a wild situation
what does happen if i take now on b3
this seems
ah queen to d1 was played yeah so sorry
three i take on c8 it feels like the
most natural yeah to do
and now i don't go d7 d7 probably yeah
this sound actually just helps you but
i'm just playing b2 next move right so
let's go bishop to
i think so
every time i go bishop to f4
c5 yeah bishop c5 is such a problem in
every line that's that's a big problem
it's such an issue
so in that case i'm going to start with
bishop to d4 okay i can dig that
it also stops b2 actually that's pretty
nice
yeah
it doesn't feel like the natural move
the natural side of the bishop because
first of all yeah i'm just hoping
by the way
so many things have changed in the
position and and so many new details
right in the position it's such a crazy
line and now rook to f2 unfortunately
knight takes f3 at some point after
exchange uh after the exchange of
afternoons
but still we have to keep going with
this move rook to f2 how do you continue
i mean i'm starting to wonder knight xf3
just wins right so let's see you cannot
take with the rook because
hg2 is a checkmate so you have to take
with the queen now the question is do
you have any sort of big checks you do
because after this you just simply take
yep that's good enough
i mean there are other wins but this is
good enough this is over yeah so what
what are we trying to find see how do
you defend maybe you have to go rogue
somewhere not rock c8 but that's so sad
right i mean the position might already
be very sad
position might be just simply lost at
this point let's go to rook f2 i mean
there's still some tries because like
yeah
yes but rook f2 i was a little bit
concerned even
after a move such as this one
that's a checkmating threat you cannot
move the knight because i take on e3 the
cb3 actually played so we are and he's
taking on c8 immediately i expect rick
takes you it also replay immediately as
well
and let's see what gregory has planned
because i don't really see it i have a
feeling there's no plan uh
perhaps after a bishop to d4 he might
have missed ricochet too
this is one of those positions yeah in
which you end up in this situation right
after queen to h3 you see your opponent
just blitzing out the moves
and you start understanding that most
likely
the complications favor black
yeah but it's an understanding that you
have with like two minutes and you know
that there's nothing you can do about it
because you have to make moves right so
you just have to uh pray
you make moves you pray and you hope
that there is going to be something at
some point in the game playing as well
after
rook takes c8 it doesn't seem like
there's anything probably you're going
to resign uh i don't see it
so it's a problem our evaluation is that
black is winning right oh my god i
didn't realize black is winning that
much like we were we were like
discussing like this is still
interesting minus eight i might not say
like black is just totally one we just
turned on the engine this is uh we don't
analyze with engines but we do confirm
some things we do tell you guys when we
turn them on just so that we confirm our
analysis but we thought black was doing
very well we didn't expect it to be like
minus a million it is seven minus seven
eight it's it's over
so this is a very important result
especially for your young yi uh with the
black pieces with the black pieces of
being the third highest rated player in
the event 26.85 it's a great win for the
chinese it's a great win and and a very
shaky start for a young gregory oparin
because he did have a double white in
the first two games
and he only managed to uh gather
half a point that's not a lot it's not
not a lot um
all right so perhaps we will stay with
this one because i have a feeling we're
going to see a resignation any time so
yeah well we only have two minutes we
might as well stick with the you know
like the chas vultures everybody is
we want to see black we want to see the
blood
the blood is being spilled here and
you're playing just a great game with
the black pieces i especially like the
the speed with which he played this move
starting with queen e7
it was just
very nice technique very
nice out of the board technique that was
experienced that was experienced a lot
of the times you see these games and
when you don't watch them live it's hard
to understand that but perhaps the
sequence with queensland 97 rooks you'd
actually won the game yeah because he
played it so quickly he had such a
concrete understanding that the queen
belonged to the queen on the king side
uh and the complications would favor him
even with us with a trash bishop on h7
this was incredible it was always very
very well done by you just showing how
strong he is and we don't know actually
the evaluation but psychologically when
you see your opponent just making moves
in 30 seconds and you spending two three
four minutes each and every move and
dropping down to your last five minutes
psychologically you're already beaten at
this point yeah i agree it's just very
difficult to recover
from that position it doesn't matter
what the position on the board is it's
the psychological pressure that you you
get in so 55 seconds for
uh
greg
and this is not a good balance not
either
and he has played something i don't
actually know it is in his hands and we
do see a knight dropping down i'm
telling you this is the move that he
missed bishop to d4 rook to see roxy too
yeah because knight d4 just covers rook
c2 there's such a sad move i i think he
he saw this move bishop to d4 he saw
that the knight has to get kicked back
uh probably to d7 to defend against d7
block that pawn on d6 and after that
maybe you can take on b3 and have a
normal position
you get to this position and then you
the hammer drops the hammer draws drop
you see rook to c2 that was the one you
understand that before i was winning
though
like bishop d4 knight g4 was winning i'm
just curious that's
yeah because you take money forward
perhaps the second option yeah it's
minus a million too
perhaps a second option yeah also
winning not as winning but pretty good
yep yep knight to d4 and let's see what
he's going to do right now
i mean the sample
i think
is taking on d6 there is a little kind
of trap i don't know how to set it up to
where like i get this knight on d4 to f4
but i can't actually there's no way
there's no way right
yeah no way whenever you uh remove the
knight from d4 i'm picking up f3
yeah the thing is that i don't know if
bishop d6 is even threatening
knight f3 or like or knight hd49 thanks
to g4 yeah
knight f3 for sure not because you take
back and then right right right i meant
that the knight moved somewhere
or something yeah but knight x g4
actually might be mine might be through
already
yeah this is this is just over you know
bishop d6 and it also
takes away
white's last hope
the last hope was that these d6 spawn
would create some kind of
threat
queen
back rank because there's a bishop on h7
i don't know something but with
the pawn gone i think so are the hopes
for
uh the mizzou student
yeah gregorio
right now it seems to be falling
under the sharp sword of the chinese
player so speaking of sharp since
it's during his turn sure uh let's
switch to the theodore game because we
actually oh yeah
a lot happened there they actually
followed
our analysis
pretty much to the t
well yeah they even went like bishop
takes
yeah
we we saw this bishop f5 and we
considered pawn takes f6
yes rook d8 he actually played bishop d3
first but i don't think it matters
takes rook h8 and then f4 anyway
queen b6 which we considered attacking
b2 and f6 he goes knight b5
queen takes up six
knight takes d4 c takes d4 so it's the
current position now the pawn is
obviously poisoned because i if you take
i take twice and go rook h1
uh rook h1 queen f4 i assume is a
current threat even though it's not a
winning threat it's just
an okay threat
roger one will probably not take on f4
because that will allow queen to f3 and
that exchange is the queens and most
likely white is going to have a better
end game um
yeah let's go with that it's just the
threat right now feels one of those
situations in which the threat is more
difficult to parry than the execution
right
um i mean so how do you like black's
main thread might be to just take on f4
immediately because you don't have rook
f1 oh right so let's defend that pawn
right queen s3 f3 or queen to e4 you
know what let's centralize the queen
centralize the queen all right let's
just start giving random checks
hopefully
sticks that's two that's right
and no but hero
rookie eight i'm not worse
but i don't know if i'm better oh yeah
so you take take take on each one of
four they're gonna have four and
with the pawn on
d4 i don't feel i'm worse like you're
definitely weak no no no no i'm not
worse i'm not sure black's better but
not playing for a loss for sure we do
have
no moves at least no no we do have a
move
we just played queen
which we were also considering this was
our first instinct and
queen h
well chuck i think anyway
christopher are you on your members
finishing a draw nothing really mattered
in that game queen h4
and i guess you go queen g3 right
because if you go g3
i'm assuming queen h2 should be okay
at least okay
at the very least okay we exchange we go
to h2 i don't think it matters which
rook i use for this takes take we take
take take on b2
at least okay it should be okay yeah you
take and i go king e6 and i should be
able to pick up the pawn somehow
yes yeah it looks fine
it's actually queen b6 setting up
a very important threat of
d3 that's a big one
what a move what a move to fight in like
no time
oh by the way there's no time
yes like one minute 59 seconds for a
theodore right now five minutes for uh
beer
with how many moves to go 40 moves to go
that is a crazy move queen b6 but at the
moment right now because you have a oh
you don't have a check on these five you
don't yeah that's the
specifics of the position this king on
f7 is surprisingly hard to reach the
rook on h5 is defending against d5
that's a problem okay d3 is a bit of a
threat huh all right d3 is a threat
queen takes b2 is a threat it's not a
bad threat either yeah uh maybe not now
actually
yes no i mean d3 is the bigger threat
but if you pair d3 there's nothing wrong
with taking on b2
all right well
was this a move that the young dane
missed missed i definitely missed it
because it's on the tank right now but
queen b6 is a very cool move it's a hard
move to spot many times because you're
looking at the checks from the other
side you just got from b6 b6 yeah you
just got to f6 f6 and now it goes back
now you're going back to b6 yeah not not
easy not easy but
found bob almost feels like a backward
move right it's not backwards not
backward but it feels bad it feels like
right now it does feel like a backward
move
um
what do we play here though good
question uh i mean queen d3 is probably
ah
actually you don't have a good way to
defend against rook to h you're just
dead yeah here this is just game over
here's game over right up to h1 and i
pick up dirk on a1
uh rook to d2 well immediately i picked
up the rook on a1
uh we went though ladura has won but we
expected that result from a while ago
lederer has beaten smyrn so he joins the
plus one group
uh probably going to be joined by you
young
my goodness so many decisive results
already yeah in the age
well i lost my internet hold on
you lost your internet but i did not
that's what matters the most yeah this
is at least what matters as of right now
um
queen to b6 no but that's such a big
moment right now right and it's such a
difficult question to answer three
minutes look at this three minutes left
for uh beer
that's a problem
okay so wait wait wait wait okay i do
see c5
did he play c5 no he's playing with b3
all right we kind of missed this idea
we're missing this uh sideways sideways
feeling like backwards moves right
all right
there's options here
i saw this idea of queen to b3 but only
after c5 so my
my plan was to go c5 first and now if
you take on b2 to go queen to b3 and
exchange the queens
and probably
draw this position
somehow
so queen b3 first
no c5 we're not giving you nothing it's
a greater version
for sure
seconds i could play queen
c7 maybe ec7 is on the board
it's the most logical move because it
retains p7 defended and it's threatening
f4 kind of with the check because rook
h1 queen x4 will be checked
um
yeah this looks normal
the universal queen f3 but it's just a
repetition by the way d3 is still some
sort of a threat right kind of right
you don't really know when this move is
a threat but it feels like it's almost
always a threat because queen takes
queen d4 and you can never exchange the
queens because of the rook h1 trick down
the road
yeah no
so
how do we continue right now
three minutes for beer that's crazy only
41 seconds for the other
such a big moment
okay queen to g3 do we go back no but we
if we go back you're probably going to
take so
queen to f3 what if i just go queen to
f3
i offer
this option of repeating with queen to
pieces
yeah that's just
black take it here right well if you
take i take on bc no i'm in the
repetition
i don't think i ever take on c right
right
right
uh maybe d3
let's just just because they're not my
bonds right
i don't care about my opponent
you cannot take with the queen or with
the rook i think
no so if i take with the rook obviously
you're going to have one check and then
pick up the rook at least and if you
take with the queen and queen see
on the board
so let's see
here black should blitz out queen b6
just repeat once repeat once
get get that point sometimes it's
difficult when you don't have this
practice right
to
to just do it just repeat it you have to
do it
he goes for it but he is basically where
he left him in 40 seconds
yeah he didn't gain any time zero
seconds he did get closer to move 40 so
that's a plus but that's about it
he actually
got exactly in the same position as he
was
so queen to b6 on the board now we're
probably going to sequence b3 right
i don't know it's not the only move
uh i liked your c5 but it also seemed
like it was just a draw
it just seems like a worse version than
queen to p3 if you don't have this move
d3 and this is probably what he's
spending his time right now his time on
right now yeah nico
so we are down to a minute 45
in this wild position
he needs to make a decision but it also
seems to be petering out to a draw right
surprisingly this is one of those crazy
games where a lot of things happen a lot
of kings were in danger but
it is possible that we just go into some
drawing
i guess if you
do play this move
d3 maybe i can just simply go queen to
e3
really
so on rookie you have queen takes d3 or
queen c5 and d4 we're not going to find
the answer to that one because oh he
played king
whoa whoa
what the
giving [ __ ]
what is that
what what is that and nico is in
complete shock right i mean i've been in
complete shock
is he thinking that after queen bee took
queen e2 he's slightly better in the end
game no i think he wants to go king g3
oh
ballsy
he wants to go up he wants to go up
right that's such a wow
such a crazy decision that is an insane
insane decision but 10 seconds
10 seconds for mikko he needs to make
come on you cannot leave yourselves a
little time
four seconds and he picks up
the pawn on between immediately king to
g3
wow back to 30 seconds for nico all
right but now white has threats right
rookie b1 and this game is over you you
has one but let's go back to this one
20 seconds and by the way robson did
finish in a draw against a misha yeah we
more or less
what do you play here as black it's
actually a question
and he only has seven seconds to find
the answer
i'm going to c3 exchange the queens make
a draw
if it feels pretty dry still anyway
right even if you do lose a pawn
although you can't take and go rogue d7
what am i talking about
oh but then work c5 at the end rook c
rook c5 yeah the sideways moves will
keep missing yeah
and that pawn on c3 should be enough
counter play
yeah we'll we have some interviews ready
but since some of the players are with a
minute minute 30 we might hold off on it
let's just simplify this position first
yeah let's let's at least get to some
clarity here because we might be close
to it finally let the players exchange
the queens get into some sort of an
equal end game and then we'll move on if
it's equal right i'm not really sure if
it's equal very unclear but what a move
what a move king
king f2 and king g3 what a concept
the young dane can play also you kind of
have to take because i just noticed rook
h3 is a thread
rook 2h
i was actually looking at rook h3 in uh
here right and then queen h2 mate but
there's no creation no because you can
just take it
so uh
and it's funny because after queen h2 i
was actually calculating
now it's like okay the king is safe
there
eureka
all right let's see um
okay so he has to take he he did go for
that queen takes c3 he takes c3 and i
guess d7 equal pawns you're going to
pick up one
i mean there's nothing else to do here
for white probably after rook two uh d7
do you go to f6 or e6 i think you just
get you get the tempo i think so you get
the tempo and now you want it to go to
c5 yeah this is where i'm not so sure
how to evaluate this oh man this
four rook end games are so difficult
i have no idea who's better in this
position
i mean okay white is blessing for a win
but do you actually get there well first
this is the moment right now in only 30
seconds for the year and i don't think
there's another
maybe rook to d3
maybe i was thinking about rook d3 but
the move
c5 rook c3 rook c8 i mean at least
you're a pawn up no how would you mean
actually b5 is gone if i was coming yeah
yeah nope
b5 look to a three
i'm gonna say
b5 will come at some point you'll have
to run yeah yeah that's true no it's uh
most likely just a draw yeah i think
that if you go target the c3 pawn maybe
it's too close to a draw maybe you can
see what you need to do that's what he
played roxy wanna maybe defend on the
fourth rung but still this doesn't feel
like
no you also have rook to d7 exchange a
pair of rooks
so for example if you try to go
something along the lines of c8 now i
can just exchange a pair of rooks
uh oh never mind you don't exchange
editors check yeah it's just a check so
he's played with c5 rook c3 is what we
expect
and
yeah nico still has to prove the draw
here
but king is six maybe rookie three and
then the other rook is getting in you
know but i was just gonna go to f6 ah
but you haven't decided
six yeah yeah that's not that's a
terrible technique yeah this might be
just lost so 35 is coming the worst
technique
um
okay how do you make a draw i don't know
yeah it's not that easy
um
maybe it's not a draw maybe
black is going to suffer this for a
while
well
while the players are still thinking uh
perhaps we will get that interview in
so let's get that interview set up
because this is going to be an endgame
nico's going to suffer but we're going
to let him let him do that
we have a special guest with you guys in
just a second
and what a decision king to f2 was by
beer with only a few seconds left on his
clock 30 to be more precise he played
that move king to f2
going with the king all the way to g3
enforcing
this queen trade quite a nice concept by
the young dane
beautiful moment right now we're going
to have to wait and see whether he will
be able to convert this extra pawn that
he right now enjoys in this four rook
end game
and
in the meantime we
will have an interview in just a second
one of the victors
of today's round that is
benjamin gledura who is right now
in the studio with
me benjamin welcome to the show thank
you so much congratulations a big
victory with the white pieces against
one of the more experienced players in
the fields elias mary tell us a bit
about yesterday
against you yang yi we left it off we
left
the live show when you had quite a nice
position quite uh some chances to
potentially convert how did you feel
about your game yesterday yeah i thought
i i played really well yesterday
especially in the opening
i had no trouble at all
and then
i could kind of
i mean we went to an end room where i
had just a slight advantage and then i
built up that advantage
and then i got the winning position
unfortunately i didn't
have too much time
like around move 40 so i didn't play the
best move
and
then he defended really well he found
the only ideas
and then
i was still winning but i couldn't
finish
still that must have been an encouraging
sign for you getting a better position
and putting a lot of pressure on the top
seed of the event did you feel that way
yeah exactly i didn't expect that at all
i mean he is a
very strong player and he was white so i
was
i just wanted to make a draw basically
before the game but then during the game
i was very ambitious and right now you
started off with the white pieces the
first white piece uh of this event for
you and you are facing smearing how did
you approach this game
yeah so he is a
a very strong player as well he's a
little bit older than me
but
but he has a lot of experience we call
them experience
here in the studio so i was expecting
the klim's indian he plays
he's an expert yeah he's playing this
indian basically his plays for his own
life yep yep so but he surprised you
with these movies yeah so after two
years i was out of book already
and then you came up with this dc4
line e4b5 it is a very interesting line
and i didn't check this obviously before
the game so i was kind of afraid of this
because i guess he checked it so of his
preparation potentially but he was
spending some time that was uh probably
a good sign for you
yeah well i also play a lot of things in
against knight f6 e6 so
iris he also prepared for something else
absolutely and he went knight to b6 and
you guys got
into this uh topical line nowadays
when did you feel like you're more or
less starting to take over
so i knew about this plan i knew about
this as3 bishop e31 plan
and
this is probably the best i wasn't sure
if it's
like
anything special but
i was like it's a very stable position
have you just go bishop p2 castle
while he has some pawn i mean his pawn
structure is very bad and this is
exactly what she did and now he played
this move king to b8 yeah i wasn't sure
about that move because it's kind of a
waste of
time gives you enough time to get some
pressure on the uh the c4 pawn and i
think just that he has to go f5
immediately instead of king
yes
and then
i wanted to take and then g takes f
series but
i think this is a better version for him
compared to their game
put some pressure on g2 potentially yes
um but i would have run
knight d2 bishop f3
rg8 and bishop f3 right yes but yeah
it's a complicated position
quite a complex uh yeah maybe knight to
b3
a lot of options for both sides it seems
like uh but he did play this move king
to b8 and after knight to d to f5 you
guys got to this position it just felt
like a better version for you yes so
after rook f1 i was kind of happy
because i have a pretty straightforward
pan plan sir
bishop d2 and then green e4 and he has
many weaknesses like the c4 pawn e6 1r
and you just exchanged his main attacker
exactly
it's an unpleasant position for him
yeah there's rook dj i was surprised to
see that move but
iris his idea was that some point he
wanted to play h5 h4
if i
play g3
so
it was logical but i thought that
this does not work out
but you had your plan you wanted to go
bishop d2 you wanted to go into e4 and
you did
um
you see yeah originally i wanted to play
g3 here
but then he had queen c6 and i wasn't
sure about this
queen to c6 no
obviously you cannot take because if you
take then the knight on f3 is hanging
so
so if i cannot tell then i'll sound
better because i can play knight h4 94
but
maybe he can defend the pawn with rook
e8
i mean i thought that i'm better but
it's not that decision remains
complicated
you wanted more i'll say so yeah i went
for the porn
so i took and
i mean i still have the point why yeah
why not the pawn is a pawn
you would get a gold membership in uh
yasser cerrone's uh pawn grabbing club
rook takes e6 knight takes d2 rook takes
it tonight to f4 did you feel like he
has enough compensation were you at all
worried
about your king
no because after king f1 the knight on
f3 is just so
such a good piece i mean
black doesn't have j through g1
and you cannot really remove the knight
from f3 yeah so
otherwise it's the c4 pawn is still
and this is what we kind of understood
once you made this very nice move
redirecting the knight from c3 to e3
covering up the e-file but most
importantly taking yes
now maybe we were kind of low on time
and i was calculating knight e5 for a
while instead of knight even
and then he would take knight d3
f4
naruto
and then i will stop i i started to
calculate clean a2
route j1
things are giving e3
rookie one clean d4 route
green their c4 and i thought that this
works out because 95 rupees takes e5
very nice but i just didn't want to risk
anything yeah why why risk it when you
have this move knight to d1 followed by
knight to e3 and after that it was just
smooth sailing actually you guys
followed a line that we were looking at
it felt quite hopeless for a black nice
victory for you uh who do you have
tomorrow measurement
i think i'm playing theodore big game
tomorrow he's having a wild game right
now just pittering out into more uh calm
waters good luck tomorrow thank you so
much
and uh we still have a few games
left actually the one that we have right
now on the screen is the big battle
between haru the union and zhu zhang
chao
in the b group and let's see actually
what is happening in that one oh my
goodness
well
a much more tame end game in this one
bishop to c6 was played last move now
rook takes e5 unfortunately doesn't seem
like it's working for white
so he played the move c4 allowed bishop
takes d5 c takes d5
26 is the move that's it three minutes
and 40 seconds for zhu zhang chow and
four minutes for harutinion and actually
zhu zhang shao just left
he got off the board where did he go
uh where did he go and he only has three
minutes to come back to the board but
also the position oh the position is
come wait no way right i guess so
there's a lot of things happening there
he's uh having some uh i think we're
stuck yeah
yes never mind so that's why he left
they probably
we just we just it just got updated got
it i just got updated on each s for some
reason yep they just reached move 40
what do we have here
black's better doesn't know how much
i mean this knight on d6 is a monster
the pawn on d5 is not going anywhere the
bishop 26 has been trapped and a5 is
dropping
so it might be just winning
i just don't know if it is
but it's pretty close to it right
this knight on d6 is such a beautiful
such a good piece it is such a good
piece
yeah and
i actually don't see a great way to get
this rookie involved into uh into the
game because
rook to e1 is most likely going to be
met with either the simple knight to e4
maybe even king to f6 king to f6
potentially bishop to d7 and then maybe
you can create some ideas
um
connected with the penetration on e6
with the rook but
that's unnecessary you can just simply
go knight to e4 um
not looking great i have to say
for the white side and we are probably
going to
be following that particular line
because rook to u1 is on the board but
while we wait for these players to kind
of agree on what the assessment of the
position is in that one we do have one
of the victors of today's round you
young yi uh first of all congratulations
welcome to the show welcome back to uh
st louis uh what does it mean to come
here to st louis and play this
tournament yeah since my uh second time
go to saint louis club yeah our first
time in
2019 2019 yeah in play a rapid annually
yeah
today
today i'm a very pleasure yeah in here
yesterday i
have better position yeah difficult game
against benjamin yeah very difficult
yeah
in
the game i feel my position is a lost
position yeah but you escaped yesterday
that was an encouraging sign for you as
well i was telling benjamin that was
encouraging sign for him because he put
some pressure with the black pieces
against the top seed but also for you
right because it's nice to escape those
type of situations now
today you played with the black pieces
against another very promising player
grisha oparin how uh what was the
strategy going
and today uh
interested in game uh in opening uh i
chose
difference because i know my opening the
um paper catalog catalog yeah yeah play
very many games yeah after e6 probably
never
yeah many games yeah today i
play edge
today i play a choice slap yeah maybe
surprise from my opponent
and play knight to f3 and you guys got
into this very topical very
mainline
variation
bishop to g4 i think
more or less both of you guys were
spending some time but not a lot right
you guys knew what was happening here
no
yeah um
usually i play quite
many games today i first time play
black you play the white side in
in this situation maybe
you play queen e2 yeah
no no
no no
yeah you're here
i play oh knight to h4 no knight to h4
yeah yeah queen to e2 yeah yeah
yeah queen two maybe three games or four
games yeah yeah yeah but he played this
move knight to each four yeah a bit more
of a forcing situation knight to d5
knight to g2
yeah yeah along a long sinker a5 because
uh
first i think knight b6 mm-hmm bishop e2
i think bishop
but
probably a very normal
situation you decided to reinforce this
bishop one before with the move a5 quite
a normal move natural move in this type
of situations yeah bishop to b3 knight
to a6
he yeah here are very important
precision because uh yeah a long thing
actually is a c4 i know c4 may be no
good but
if you i play cd take
knight before
sorry no no first the knight before no
queen d4
yeah oh knight takes before first yeah
take
on e3 yeah yes
uh
exchange the coin source yeah yeah take
knight six
and pancake perhaps
yeah i think the ufo
sorry
um first h5 yeah h5 first yeah bishop
should be here for ui yeah
so maybe i think a white position
slightly better yeah i have no chance to
win
yeah and that rook will nicely defend
the bishop on b3 so for example if you
try to do something like this
hsn bishop is a very bad yes
yes we were looking at this bishop and
we understood that you have to find a
way to get it open and one of the ways
to get it open was to go f5 at some
point right yeah
and that's why you decided to lock this
bishop with the move c4 quite a nice
decision by you yeah
yeah here may be nice too bad yeah i
think f5 but
i missed no nokia f5
yeah no check no change f5 first after
yeah f5 right now yeah bishop by i think
i think it should be one first yeah i
missed take take wherever you are
there
i'm missing 93
credit for 93
yeah okay yeah i don't know is this a
good position so take take you take
maybe see the position black is okay
yeah maybe even knight d5 yeah maybe
yes the bishop becomes quite active yeah
yeah very important yeah yeah
so
you took on c2 you were not very happy
with this move
and maybe my opponent 55 is slightly
mistake i think yeah maybe i think uh
here
clint or rudy two yeah
rook d yeah maybe yeah
so d5 was a bit too optimistic
yeah maybe
in my opening
after my opening the time of tribal yeah
yes yeah and this is what we were very
impressed right now myself and alejandro
for the next few moves you almost
blitzed out every single move okay you
played this move queen to e7 22 minutes
and 50 seconds next move 22 minutes and
he was burning a lot of his time right
he was dropping all the way to eight
minutes and you still have 21 minutes
and you are still blitzing out your
moves um
now
how did you come up with this concept of
just playing this complicated position
as fast as you could
yeah because if you i launching maybe my
opponent happened many times yeah
so i played too fast yeah
you were not worried at all that he
might
you might miss something and you know
yeah
because
i feel my possession maybe only more for
claim 6 95 okay yeah so you felt safe
right now
and he definitely did not feel very safe
and he played this move b3 quite a big
big blunder but yeah
because maybe my often missed ch4 yeah
yeah
here i think maybe my opening
queen divine is better yeah i think
i don't know
it yes
i'm just going to cheat right now yeah
you're still completely weird yeah
minus minus four yeah the situation i
think after qh4 is already hopeless
um
a huge victory for you with the black
pieces who do you have tomorrow
tomorrow i just
um
play
i remember tomorrow i play
really
yeah robson yeah excellent uh big battle
that will be we wish you good luck and
we'll see you tomorrow okay thank you so
much thank you thank you for joining
and right now we see on the screen sam
savion still
walking around the playing horse still
in the hit of a battle
playing against
jacobian aram who we see on the left
side thinking
pondering his next decision
big big moment we still have two games
in the a group the one between beer
and nico theodore and
the battle between hacobian
and sam savion and
already two decisive results
in the a group alejandra welcome back
well thank you
nice interview there with
winners of the tournament today as they
are now tied for first place uh both
pandering ladura and yu yangi
uh fascinating strawberries i think that
the a group was very boring yesterday
and there's no other way to say it but
today they really brought in the fight i
mean these games are really wild and i
think we're going to have three decisive
results
because
the more i look at it i was announcing a
little bit while you were interviewing
yu yang yi but i think this end game
between uh beer and theodore it's just
busted for black i think i don't think
there's any real way to defend this yeah
it's not just the extra pawn it's the
activity
of the right it almost feels like you're
in some sort of some you're you're going
to get zugs wrong very very soon like
actually what do you play right now like
let's say you go here
you go
here's seven yeah but then i go king h6
oh that's
that's probably even easier that's what
i'm saying yeah you might be in some
sort of a sizzle you might just be dead
immediately right and if you do this i
think i can go like this and then g6
king h7 yeah yeah this looks lost
yeah i think this is just very lost uh
after g4 so i expect beer to win as well
and it all comes down to this hakopian
game right
we we said it's equal right we said it's
equal i'm still going to stand by that
100 percent sure
is putting some pressure on him yeah the
engine actually thinks black is better
uh we left it off
a long time ago long time ago yeah yeah
when we left it off it was actually when
we left it off it was equal
but
somehow samia has actually outplayed
our arm from a pretty dry position
and the thing is this knight is going to
go to g7 and f5 and if it gets there
you're in trouble
so this 92 is a bit stuck
right now uh 25 minutes for sam savion
25 minutes for aram and he just played
this move f4 now at first not the movie
right to play at first the move that you
played because you didn't have anything
else but why did he play this move f4
king e5
i think if i was just too strong yeah
game five and then d4 and then you're
completely bound
by black's forces i think i think you
have to take e5 to your own control
maybe f4 was a very important move also
honestly you don't ever know when f5 is
going to come yeah uh it might solve all
of your issues uh go knight g3 attack
both pawns yeah so i do think white is
the one playing for a draw but
man i'm going to be honest i saw the
engine evaluation of minus 0.7 and i i
don't see it i mean you don't see the
0.7 i understand blacks better right i
definitely understand blacks better
black is got the open file the pass ball
better king better knight but but
there's no entries there's no entry
squares there's no real other targets
everything is you can't play d4 like i
don't even know what the move here is
it's not an option king c5 impossible
because it worked to c2
what is that oh my god sorry i was
thinking knight seven knight the f5 yeah
but i just said i'll go knight d4 and
continue this dance you still don't have
rook c3 you could you do have rook c1
although i'm not sure how happy you are
about doing that
maybe you are happy that's right
but
ah so if you go here you just simply go
here
yeah
yeah no i mean still unpleasant yeah i
was thinking something nice something
slightly something slide yeah i don't
know how slight it is but the more you
look at it the more maybe it's difficult
to play for white because i was thinking
92 but i couldn't make it work
what do you play here you start seeing
ghosts you start seeing ghosts you you
start seeing problems too it's not just
ghosts you do see a lot of ghosts but
you also see real problems and it's hard
to distinguish between the two in this
complicated end games and what else do
we have left in the b group i
think the big group took care of uh of
themselves right because there were too
many draws that never really went
anywhere
uh berg
is well
there's some pressure on ali morandi
right now is there a wedding or it's a
dead draw
right right
like there's no in between no
so if you take you can you have this
nice cute tactic but it doesn't lead to
it doesn't do anything yeah
this is just a draw
so
i mean you cannot move this knight from
f6 because knight takes f5 finishes the
game but i don't see anything
like so productive
to do in this position
maybe you go queen d6 and just attack
c5 yeah
knight e4 knight takes f5
knight takes g7 knight takes d6 knight
e6 and you have to defend this it's
technically a draw it's actually a
pretty easy draw considering the pawn
positioning
but
i don't know if you want to get into it
so queen to d6 yeah the only other way
to do this would be to just give up the
pawn with king h7
and then knight e4 and then
we pretend that there's some kind of
fight the problem is queen e5
i wasn't able to find a good
that's a good point yeah
that is indeed a good point so what if i
just continue like this but you have no
threat right you know
95 yeah again i don't know if black is
really losing this because i mean you
still have moves like queen a7 you still
have move house like like this might
just be a draw to be honest
so
well
you suffer yeah
you're going to suffer for you will
suffer you might actually be lost yeah
but those are the kind of things we're
looking at it's not clear to me
if black has
solved all of his issues but i think
he's pretty close
as you were mentioning yeah it's either
it's either or you're lost or you're
completely lost it's after the next
couple of moves
it feels to me that this king on g2 is
too weak that there should be a way what
about the other game
the last one we haven't looked at yeah
this is the one with the most potential
for a decisive game i think
and we with him with some transmission
errors as well because after you want to
have a feeling there's
a couple more moves
played yes
with zero seconds
i don't think that's accurate well he
might be because uh
made thanksgiving control yeah
so what is going on if i go like
knight e4
i guess king d3
maybe that's not so pleasant
can i go queen to b3
that is very fancy mr christian kirilla
rook a1 bishop d5
wow look at this tactical genius over
here
wow that's really nice actually
yeah i don't think you can uh actually
do you have this move
so much for the tactical genius it's
over it's over
my tactical
genius has uh
his widowed away has died yeah can't do
that
but things to consider for white right
because this is the
the way you get out of problems
all right so rook to you one
probably still thinking
what is the option what is the
alternative by the way king f6
by the way do we have that
yes it's not about the position we
currently have one it's not a bad option
actually because you just keep the
knight on d6
but i go bishop d7
so now you have to go rook to e4 right
i think it might be
maybe not the only move but here i have
knight e4 yeah instead of um 94. yeah
the part the point is you can't go to
the third rank right
either here or here because knight c5
and just once a piece so
you have to go to like b2
something like this
but even here knight c no no i'd see if
i would lose a piece what am i doing
let's see if i should take c4 so
yeah
yeah but this is probably probably
asking for it though
because you do have knight f3 coming
that's very it's a crazy auntie crazy
black is better black is the one playing
for a win that's what we think and we
think so but alejandro as we get close
uh
to finishing up the program uh tonight
let's uh check the results up to this
point and we're going to start with
group eight what do we have here well we
got group a ray rox and drew against abi
mitra in a crazy bad venue where things
speeded up pretty quickly uh benjamin
gladua did beat elias mirren in this new
vienna and grisha oparin uh lost a
complicated slav against yuyani allowing
these two players uh both benjamin and
yani to go to first place they might be
joined by jonas bier as he is currently
in the superior position actually just
winning against nicolas teodoro and we
will
remain to see
the game between jacobian and savion
as they are currently fighting it out we
think seven is better we're not
guaranteeing that even but we do think
he's better
um
and maybe sam will join the group of
leaders we might have up to four
decisive games today meanwhile in the b
group we had a bunch of draws to start
off the day uh on tip of duck
christopher you drew guillermo vazquez
and brandon jacob some drew camille
dragoon in games where
not that much happened uh john burke is
still trying against jj ali morandi but
i we we think this is just a draw
and then thinking on how to tune in is
the game that we're looking at he is
currently
suffering a bait against joe jian ciao
and we're gonna have to remain to see if
he survives that one
quite uh an intriguing round i have to
say uh the a group started off slow
yesterday but right now they're
definitely picking up the pace i have to
say i'm uh quite impressed with the way
benjamin gledura is playing up to this
point putting a lot of pressure with the
black pieces as well as with the usual
white pieces where you can place a lot
of pressure and he did put enough
pressure to get the full point today
yeah that's what he's doing yeah he's
taking advantage of his white he uh
actually put pressure with black so far
a great tournament for him but it's only
been two rounds plenty of action to come
in the next few days christian and we'll
be here to call it out absolutely we
will see you tomorrow at 3 30 p.m we're
going to start our live show the games
start at 1 p.m central time see you
tomorrow with round three see ya
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you